Who watches the intellectual
watchmen?
When it comes to historians,
especially those purporting to tell
the truth about the founding of
America, the Nobel Prize winner,
James Buchanan, and the godfather
of Austrian economics, Ludwig von
Mises. It's Phil Magness
of the American Institute for
Economic Research.
Magness has a Ph.D.
from George Mason University School
of Public Policy, and he's written
or co-written books on what he calls
the moral mess of higher education,
Abraham Lincoln's plan for black
resettlement after emancipation
and on the 1619 Project.
He's emerged as that project's most
dogged critic, finding that the
Pulitzer Prize winning series
developed by MacArthur Genius
Grant winner Nikole Hannah-Jones,
was quietly revised at The
New York Times website after several
prominent historians pointed out
major errors in its analysis.
She goes on CNN and someone
asked her a question about this
line, and she says, I never said
that. I never made that claim.
But of course, we know that 1776
was the founding of this country.
The project does not argue that 1776
was not the founding of the country.
Start thinking.
I had.
Seen her make that claim 20
or 30 times and I think it was
in the original text.
And I go back to the website and
it's no longer there.
Magnus has also been a leading
critic of Duke historian Nancy
McLane, whose national book award
winning Democracy in Chains
attempted to brand the school choice
movement as motivated by racism.
This whole set of
ideas has been twined
really since the beginning of our
country, these notions of extreme
economic liberty with
racial subjugation.
She said, I'm not going to even
bother
consulting anyone that works in the
public choice Buchanan tradition
and her excuse, she said this in an
interview is I don't want to tip
them off, that I've discovered their
their dirty laundry or something.
And he's a critic of Hans Hermann
Hoppe, a professor emeritus
at UNLV and a distinguished
senior fellow at the Mises Institute
who is increasingly influential
within the Libertarian Party.
Hoppe has tried to invent
this kind of carved out
counter-narrative while still
claiming to be a representative, a
message that says we can use
this propertarian concept
of the nation state to exclude
undesired groups, exclude immigrants
from crossing the borders.
And it's the complete
inversion of Jesus's thought.
And yet he's doing it under the
mantle of saying, Well, I'm the
heir, of Rothbart, who's the heir of
Mises.
Magnus also wrote an article for
reason that's inspired an ongoing
plagiarism investigation at
Princeton University of Kevin Kruse,
a high profile, very online
professor of history.
This is a guy that would tweet one
or 200 times a day
as a live stream of American
politics.
And then as soon as the the
word got out about plagiarism, he's
dropped off the face of the earth.
Reason caught up with Magness at
Freedom Fest, the annual gathering
in Las Vegas to talk about
intellectual accountability in
academia, journalism and
the libertarian movement.
Phil Magnes, thanks for talking to
Reason.
Thanks for having me.
You recently wrote a piece for
Reason where you
documented that Kevin Kruse,
the presidential historian who's
at Princeton University,
you know, seems to be guilty of
plagiarism.
You know, part of that, it's a
gotcha just because plagiarism
is a bad thing, but because Kruse
himself had called out various
people for exactly
the same thing.
Can you recap the argument against
Kevin Kruse for us?
Yeah.
So this actually started
almost two years ago.
I was asked to review
his book, One Nation Under God,
which came out in the late
2010s.
And it was a purported history
of religiosity in 20th century
America.
And he has a thesis that says that
basically it's New Deal opponents
connected to libertarians in the mid
20th century unite with the business
audiences to force
Christianity upon the
public and the religious right.
And this is like when, you know, in
God We Trust started showing
up and, you know, certain additions
to the Pledge of Allegiance.
So it's basically he makes Leonard
Reed ends up at Jerry Falwell as
briefly as his thesis.
And I'm reading this book.
And in addition to critiquing the
academic side of it, I start
noticing some of the passages.
One stood out in particular was this
obscure quote by Abraham Lincoln.
And I was like, I had seen that
before because I've done a lot of
work on Lincoln's presidency,
and it just kind of nagged on my
mind and I started digging into
some of his sources.
And then I found he had taken it
from a partially cited article
in The New York Times, but there
were real strong textual
similarities, like almost identical
sentences, and maybe one or two
words changed.
Now thought, Wait a minute, this
looks
a little.
It's lazy to say the worst, but
it's. It's plagiarism, probably.